the countdown till the super bowl is on
and you know what that means yeah
the hottest commercials with the biggest
stars are starting to drop
i was thinking football but that is true
it's a good point well let me show you
something kev
that's just as hot as a tom brady
touchdown pass
all right
michael b jordan is shirtless and in a
bathtub for amazon's new alexa ad
e.t has the exclusive blooper michael
cracking up between takes
dolly parton remade her classic 9-5 for
squarespace's super bowl ad
[Music]
i thought it would be a wonderful way to
do it and to kind of give the new
generation
a chance to actually be in the
commercial and there's more
i want to break free matthew mcconaughey
turns into
flat matt for doritos dad it's the red
one i know
the other red one i know john travolta
dances with daughter ella for scott's
miracle grow
and amy schumer is an enchanted fairy
god mayo
for helmands what are you having a
potato salad party
what can you tell us about this
commercial nothing annoys this
character more than somebody wasting
food as for half time
we give to the world and the world gives
back
this morning pepsi debuted its second
promo starring the weekend
the new 30 second spot shows the 30 year
old getting ready to take the stage on
game day
every stage a new beginning
cbs's announcers told me they'll be
watching
normally we're like calling our kids
right for five minutes
during halftime it's like no the
weekend's actually gonna be a year so
it's gonna be a great time
i'm always backstage trying to talk to
the coaches and getting ready
i hope i get a chance to go out there
during rehearsal onto the field and and
the day before
and just be able to to listen to a
little bit of it because when we're in
the middle of the game
you know we're actually doing the game
you know we had the who
we had we had prince we've had some
extraordinary shows janet jackson when
it comes to the weekend
i'm watching jim nance tracy wolfson and
tony romo
will be calling all the action for super
bowl 55 sunday on cbs
but tony was just a rookie in the booth
three years ago i just want to take you
back for a second and show you a clip
of your teammate tony when he first got
this gig
they're like okay let's just do our
first run-through game i'm like no
offense i don't know what a telestrator
is
what do i do with my hands you know it's
like that's you don't know what to do
with anything
tony have you figured it out now i'm
better with my hands
i feel like that that part of it i've
come full circle